نحن اذا استطعت ان استخدم عباره نجونا
بعجوبه من قلب دائره المواجهه كانت تتساقط
علينا الحجاره الكبيره بشكل كثيف التي
كانت تطلق نحو الشرطه التي كنا الى جانب
عناصرها ثم عندما انتقلنا من مقلب عناصر
الشرطه الى مقلب المحتاجين الاكراد
الغاضبين اطلقت نحونا ايضا ونحو الاخرين
القنابل المسيله للدموع هذه النيران
المشتعله نقترب منها نحاول الاقتراب قليلا
من النيران المشتعله في وسط جده ستراسبور
التي
ابعدت الشرطه وحدات التدخل السريع منها
ابعدت الاعداد الكبيره من المحتجين وايضا
اوقفت بعض المشاغبين طبعا اعود الى سؤالك
سقط بعض الجرحى ليست عندنا معلومات عنه
اعدادهم حتى الان ولكن الشخصيات السياسيه
الفرنسيه يتوالى استنكارها لما حصل زعيمه
اقصى اليمين تحديدا النائب التي تتراس
كتله كبيره من اقصى اليمين في البرلمان
قالت انها تستنكر ما تعرضت ما حصل اليوم
في باريس وما تعرضت له ال لم تسمي الجاليه
الكرديه وانما قالت انها تقدم تعازيها لي
اهالي الضحايا الذين سقطوا في باريس اليوم
وايضا وزير الداخليه الذي وصل الى هنا قبل
قليل هو غادر قبل قليل وصل قبل ساعه وغادر
قبل قليل حاول ان يطمئن ابناء الجاليه
الكرديه قائله انه يتوجه اليهم بتعزيه
صادقه وانه حضر الى هنا بطلب من رئيس
الجمهوريه وقال ان كل الذين طلبوا تراخيص
للقيام بتظاهرات مستنكره للاعتداء سيعطون
هذه التصاريح وان كل المراكز والمواقع
الكرديه ستحظى بحمايه خاصه قبل قليل بدا
التظاهره في مرسيليا جنوب فرنسا نظامها
محتاجون اكراد على ما جرى وصدر الدعوات
للمشاركه في تظاهره دعت اليها الجاريه
الكرديه غدا عند الساعه الثانيه عشر ظهرا
في باريس تحديدا في ساحه الجمهوريه لم
تواصل هنا وحدات مكافحه
الشغب وحدات والتدخل السريع في الشرطه
الفرنسيه لم سيل تبغلها داخل جاده
ستراسبور وانما كانت تريد على ما يبدو فقط
منع الغاضبين من الخروج من هذه الجاده
والانتشار في شوارع واحياء متفرعه عنها لا
استطيع ان اقول ان الوضع هذا نسبيا لانه
هدا في مكان وتوتر في مكان اخر والذين
تنجح الشرطه في تفريقهم داخل احد الاحياء
ينتشرون في احياء وشوارع قريبه من الحي
الذي ابعد منه او عنه
تشاهدين الاعداد كبيره يطوقون الان هذه
الجاده ويبدو ان هناك نيه لوحدات التدخل
السريع في الدخول الى جده ستراسبور التي
انتشر حول عناصر الشرطه يحاولون الدخول
اليها لابعاد المحتجين الذين يتفرقوا في
شوارع مجاوره